[Music]
one of the great challenges in learning
how to code
is to learn it properly nine times out
of ten
they get frustrated and then they give
up
well let me tell you that nine times out
of ten they were taught
the wrong way there are two main reasons
why most people give up
which are actually fixable the teaching
style is not a match
some people learn by reading some people
learn by watching
and some people learn by practicing
second reason they don't know the steps
to take to reach their goals
and then they might end up learning the
wrong things
you want to get into data science i'll
tell you the steps to get there
you want to build web applications i'll
tell you what things you have to learn
that way you don't need to waste time
searching for answers but rather use
that time
to do what you actually love building
creating something that you're proud of
with code
in this class i'm going to teach you the
fundamentals of programming
the right way the goal here is to build
a strong foundation
train your mind to think like a
programmer and to problem-solve
like an engineer all right so here's the
sudoku board
represented by a list of lists and let's
try to print that using the function
that we wrote last time
[Applause]
wow way better but let's try to solve it
using the code that we wrote so
far
as you can see no solution now why is
that
and that is because we did not backtrack
and backtracking
is as simple as adding this one line
boom it's like magic
so this is what the computer is actually
doing it is trying every single
combination of values you can put in
your sudoku board
and then if ever it gets stuck it will
backtrack and then finally
you get your answer that was pretty fun
i like that
by the end of the course you should be
able to program a sudoku solver
or any constraint satisfaction problem
but the real goal of this class
is to mode you into a confident
programmer so that you are well equipped
to tackle any other topics you're
interested in in the future
the thing about programming is once
you've mastered it the sky's the limit
and nothing is unattainable start your
programming journey
the right way welcome to programming
fundamentals
all right let's start coding
[Music]